anticipation is running high for Super
Bowl 50 to being played tomorrow in
Minneapolis while the New England
Patriots and Philadelphia Eagles are
ready for the game law enforcement is
preparing for a massive security
operation nearly 2,000 federal agents
are backing up the presence of state and
local police patrolling the region in
ways you can see and in ways you cannot
Jamie yuccas is at the NFL experience in
downtown Minneapolis the host city of
tomorrow's big game Jamie good morning
good morning there is no specific or
credible threat to the Super Bowl but US
Bank Stadium where the games going to be
held is right smack dab in the middle of
downtown Minneapolis between businesses
and across the street from a level 1
trauma hospital
that's why officials want fans to get to
the game four hours early on Sunday to
get through all the security measures
now in place inside a Blackhawk
helicopter patrolling above us Bank
Stadium Customs and Border Patrol agent
Michael Fuller explained what he thinks
a Super Bowl win will look like we want
to keep everybody focused on the game
relax have a good time Fuller's aviation
a Marine unit is flying six helicopters
to keep eyes in the sky around-the-clock
in some ways are you guys a deterrent or
you help people feel safe just by your
presence being out there we hope to be
there as a deterrent obviously
and to help everybody feel better but
we need to be prepared just in case it
really does happen in all 17 hundred
federal agents are supporting local and
state law enforcement this Super Bowl is
categorized by the US Department of
Homeland Security as a level 1 special
event meaning it has the highest threat
to public safety Philadelphia and New
England coaches they've done the X's and
O's it's game time for us and we are
ready to do what we need to do and
everywhere there are fans there is high
profile security in addition to police
and tactical gear with assault rifles
armored National Guard Humvees and
barriers protect pedestrians from
vehicle attacks every car and truck
entering the secured zone is x-rayed for
explosives and chemical weapons and
police in a hi-tech incident center are
looking for trouble on hundreds of
cameras both inside and outside the
stadium
we really need to make sure that as a
symbol of our freedom for Americans to
get together and enjoy their pastimes we
have to make sure and ensure that their
safety is first and foremost
besides law enforcement though there
will be 16 Minnesota agencies and 10,000
volunteers that will be helping out the
Minneapolis Police Department now as for
the cold that hospital across the street
for the stadium will be ready to take in
patients who have cold related injuries
including frostbite Alex Jamie yuccas
keep your gloves on Jamie at the Super
Bowl in Minneapolis thanks Jamie